notre information services mais elle
devrait plus tous nous concerner dans
les années qui viennent pour l'instant
il s'agit d'une expérience se pilote
avec l'inauguration aujourd'hui à
strasbourg du premier réseau français de
téléphone de poche ou téléphone baladeur
le be bop c'est son nom pèse 170 grammes
il était très judicieusement mise au
point par france télécom nous sommes au
début des années 1990 à cette époque le
téléphone portable c'est le radiocom
allô allô allô allô
je te reçois pas très très bien un
téléphone portable gros comme une brique
et qui pesait le poids d'une brique et
ça vous coûter un bras
peut-être même deux je te reçois pas
très bien la moto c'était pratique tu
pouvais faire de la muscu avec dont je
couche plus à cette époque pas de
smartphone pas de sms pas d'internet pas
de réseaux sociaux rien nada le néant
numérique pour téléphoner le seul moyen
c'était le téléphone filaire
alors fallait être chez soi j'ai des
amis dans un bar au boulot ou trouver
une cabine téléphonique
ils sortent de boîte dans lequel il y
avait un téléphone et ça sortait pas
toujours très bon tu insérer une pièce
ou une carte à puce est en fonction de
la distance de ton appel ça te coûte est
plus ou moins cher tu l'as acheté dans
un bureau de tabac
tu avais des unités dessus les crédits
est évidemment tu écris type art et plus
ou moins vite en fonction de ton appel
de la distance il ya des gens qui
passaient leur temps à collectionner des
cartes à puce allons le forfait ça
existe pas encore quand vous attendiez
un appel fallait rester à côté du
téléphone chez soi au boulot dans un bar
chez des amis bref fallait près du
téléphone fallait attendre ça sonne pas
là non
voilà ça va sonner la non je crois que
je vais me regarder un film sur mon
magnétoscope vhs hi-fi stéréo pal secam
ntsc dolby surround ça a sonné la wii il
y avait le répondeur mais c'était un
truc en plus et ça coûtait cher les
beavers ou les téléphones de bosch ont
envahi les trottoirs de strasbourg
téléphoner y compris à l'autre bout du
monde sur un bout de trottoir c'est
possible avec ses mini combinées de
poche
l'idée de france télécom c'était de
proposer un téléphone portable
financièrement accessible volonté en
fait d'en faire un produit de grande
diffusion
derrière be bop évoque bien le dynamisme
la vitalité le dialogue puisque le be
bop
jadis on le danser il faut être à deux
passes en or devant être installés et
formeront un maillage complet de
l'agglomération permettant de téléphoner
de n'importe quel endroit
ce téléphone fonctionne il fallait être
à proximité d'une borne publique pour la
trouver il fallait chercher un
autocollant une sorte de jeu de piste
une fois trouvée vous deviez vous
déclarez à la borne je suis là non il
n'y avait pas encore les petites barres
pour vous dire si vous aviez dû raison
ou pas petit détail non négligeable
il ne fallait pas trop s'éloigner de la
zone d'à peine 200 m max on ne pouvait
pas se déplacer d'une bande à l'autre
non on pouvait pas pour recevoir un
appel même démarche fallait trouver une
borne se connecter et attendre sans trop
se déplacer
ça y est je suis sur place non je bouge
pas tu peux m'appeler
non je préfère que tu m'appelles allez
faut raccrocher maintenant nantua
d'abord un 2 temps port-cros je suis au
début
bon je raccroche parce que sinon ça va
me coûter une blinde
c'était le principe à la même époque
apparaît une technologie concurrente est
un petit peu plus pratique le gsm en
fait c'est les débuts du téléphone
portable que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
mais ça coûtait très cher quatre fois
plus cher et oui encore une histoire
d'argent
le be bop connu un certain succès
jusqu'en mai
994 mais les prix côté gsm se sont
démocratisés et l'aventuré s'est arrêtée
en 1997
mais quand même on a compté jusqu'à
trois cent mille personnes qui
utilisaient ce téléphone cabine portable
bon il en espérait 500 mille ha
je crois que la mobilité eu raison du
pick up véritable révolution dans le
mode de télécommunications ce téléphone
de poche accompli un vieux rêve un rêve
accessible